oh my god that's the biggest fly that is  an enormous fly I know if it landed here  what you do is you go oh get it over  here because you put it there and you go  because the fly feels the pressure of  the air coming from either side so you  click it and you get it every time never  murder that fly has no idea what the  danger it's in I so hope he comes back  notice it Oh oh my god did you just  drink the fly  oh my sweet God  okay  you drunk now it's drunk I've chewed it  drink didn't realize I had any ice in  there  oh let's see let's see okay are you  ready see you ready  it's like sexy si fly just throw a  little chalk outline around it but you  didn't swallow any of it it's also there  that's why I have a good girl